IT TO THE POINT AND BROUGHT INT
IN WITH REALLY GOOD-
LOOKING POWER-PLAY.
GREAT A CHANCE AND MA THERE IS
SHOT MISSED THE
NET ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS PICK D
WITH A HUGE SAVE  AS HE LEFT IN
FIRST.JARVIS HAS A STEP INTO TH
ZONE, STEPS S HE SET JARVIS WIT
LOOKOF THE TURNOVER INSIDE THE
LINE. ONLY
HE HAD ONE TOUCH, IN MIGHT OF
BEEN BETWEEN HIS LEGS TO THE
MIDDTHE CANES PUSHING THE PACE
PLAY.
HEAVY HAD TO D D
MIDDLE OF THE ICE. ES OFF
OF TROCHECK IN,
HE HITS THE CROSSBAR  :40 LEFT
PERIOD.STAAL,
VINCENT  FOR
STAAL, HE
THE CANES ARE GOING TO GET A
SHOT OPPORTUNITY RIGHT AWAY.
TROCHECK SINCE IT ACROSS STAAL,
HIS SHOT.
GEORGI
ANDERSON HAD TO BE READY FOR
IT.
ANDERSON IS ON HION ITS WAY AND
I MEAN THE STRENGTHS.
AT THE POINT BY FOX, HE GETS IT
TO NG
TO THE COACH.
HIS HANDS ARE WELL TERAVAINEN .
ACROSS, ATTEMPT IS IT AGAIN.
WHAT A PASS THAT WAS AD JUST A
SENSATIONAL ALL-STAR AS HE WAS
LOCKED BY THE RANGERS NET,
LOOSE PUCK, ONE TOUCH  ZERO.FOR
JARVIS JARVIS. -- CHANCE
FOR PESCE.
TRIPLICATES OF LOVE TO IT.
MISSES.
IT GOES HIGH, REBOUNDING CHANCE
,  ANOUT OF THE THIRD PERIOD FO
1-0.  AHO  IT'S THE SHOT
ACROSS, REBOUND ATTEMPT.
THERE.
VATRANO BERRIES IT.
THE RANGERS TAKE A .. AND
THEY EVENTUALLY FIND A